[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's ray liotta actor producer he was in
field of dreams he was in goodfellas he
was also in the sopranos prequel the
many saints of newark and he's in the
third and final season of hannah
premieres november 24th on prime video
ray joins us on the program how many
fights have you been in in your life ray
how many fights yeah honestly one it was
in seventh grade and i was the two
grammar schools were folded into uh
uh the junior high school and some kid
we were arguing about
i think was something stupid as who had
the better food
in in the grammar schools and we went i
went down to the house because everybody
knew there was a fight
i won
but but you appear to be a tough guy in
a lot of your roles you're a tough guy
are you a tough guy
tough and what we're now not really
[Laughter]
so you're on this people like i said
i've only been in one fight
must be a great actor then to act tough
now you hit it
hey let me ask you something okay they
kept wanting me to remove the
the coffee cup the orange juice the
water you got 18 things up there
who's the guy in the red that's got his
hand up uh that is lou holtz
the former uh notre dame arkansas
headquarter you can put whatever you
want up there ray
i don't care
no i'm joking no i'm not joking
what do people say to you on a daily
basis depending on where you are what do
you get on the street
uh
you're the best looking actor that i've
ever seen in my
life no
no no no no no they'll either do they'll
either just say hello
or for a while it was you're a funny guy
uh
it's not a bad price debate
but you know it's one of those where
you're some actors are known for a role
and then you try to
escape the role a little bit or try to
do something different uh how tough is
that sure
now
the tough guy comes in
uh
my first movie was a movie something
wild and i played a maniac and i would
read and i didn't get it till i was 30
years old that's when i did my first
movie
uh
i forgot the question again about you
try to distance yourself from you know
so after something wild i did the movie
dominic and eugene with tom holtz which
was a beautiful i was a medical uh
uh student and i had to move to stanford
but uh my brother who was brain damaged
and we find out later that was because
of physical abuse but i had to leave him
it was a really beautiful story and and
feel the
dreams i didn't like hit kevin with the
bat
that was a nice one
i did a couple of muppet movies too
what kind of athlete were you
i was
okay i played soccer and and basketball
but the soccer uh i think i was better
at
but i never it just went to high school
and that was it
did you audition for field of dreams
no
no i think they just brought me in
and i think it was just an out now offer
i think
how long were you in iowa
you see um you must have seen the uh the
game that they played on the field yeah
that was beautiful they really really
did a good job
uh
so would you ask me again how long were
you in
iowa probably
two months maybe a little more
it was beautiful
have you watched that movie
no
i've never seen it
i haven't
do you not watch your movies
not a lot of them i mean a lot of a lot
of them i don't
do it
[Music]
i mean obviously it's all good fellas
and maybe a couple others
but
in general i probably have more movies
that i haven't seen
but can you watch now that you're
further removed from it
the watch a movie yeah that you were in
now
you know sometimes something i'm
changing channels and oh i was in that
one it just kept it keeps going on
well i wondered because some you know
you should listen to yourself
talk
uh i don't i don't listen to the replay
of the show
yeah all right see we're the same
well it's that i used to when i did
sportscenter the show would be over i'd
get the tape and i'd watch the entire
sports center and look at all the things
i didn't do well or right
and
were you in the beginning of that no i
got there uh
i was 10 years in so
uh
1989.
that's when i got there
but yeah they started in the early 80s
with chris berman and company but yeah i
i got there
uh late nine late 80s but i would
analyze everything i was doing and then
it was defeating the purpose so i wasn't
looking at what i did well i would i
would look at what i didn't do well and
i didn't know if that's what
would you be doing that would you be
critical of yourself if you're watching
oh yeah totally it's all about lighting
if i'm not looking good i'm done
as a matter of fact i tell i i'm not
joking you know they tell you like all
right move to your left move to your
right and i said guys just tell me like
when the light the lighting is better
over there than here and i'll move in a
second
just because you know that you're going
to look good
totally yeah and i noticed you wore the
blue shirt because of the blue eyes i
mean come on that's smart move that's a
veteran move by you right now
little did i know
[Laughter]
all right if you weren't an actor you
would have been
a musician i was just talking last night
with my fiance uh
jc
uh
a cop
or a musician like someone who knows how
to play guitar i play guitar like a
thousand years ago and
i just didn't take it i just found it
it wasn't for me
and then you like copland did you
embrace
that sort of feel you know that yeah
i i used to do ride alongs with with the
cops uh the one guy was the sergeant the
first call we had to go on it turned out
there was a body part because something
blew up in this person's house oh boy so
i've done that i i i
i researched a lot in the beginning
good fellas i had a guy who
was in it or claimed that he was in it
he actually was uh
what else did i do
i've watched our time autopsies i did a
movie where i played a heart surgeon and
i just sat back and watched them just
what they do just to get
the uh
the doctor said you've been here all the
time you want to come up here and see
what we're doing
and i said yeah and what what this
woman's chest was wide open and they
were doing heart surgery and he he said
you want to touch your heart oh boy
i said yeah i mean how many
opportunities you get with that and i
put my finger in
and and touch this woman
her
heart
what's so funny
well that's not that's unique i mean
it's not yeah a standard practice there
on the operating table
yeah totally i i still uh i did i
watched
a brain
uh authority because what i'm always
doing uh
what the hell was the one i did without
anthony hopkins is this where they're
feeding you the brain was it hannibal
yeah
yeah and they said what what do you want
to eat for it
and i said well i can't imagine it
tastes good just give me dark meat
chicken i just don't like dark meat
chicken so they put it there was there
and then tony feeds it to me and
i i eat dark
chicken
dark meat chicken uh we're talking to
ray liotta the actor producer and uh
he's in the third and final season of
hannah
what made you jump on this roll
cash well you haven't admitted before
that you've taken roles for just the
money i have
because i needed it you know i've
definitely had an up and down career
that's now on a slow rise
um
yeah i used to watch open uh uh brain
surgery that one was crazy but and
the guy's awake because i didn't know
how i was supposed to do it you know
and he was awake and he was there and
then i turned around it was a 405
freeway
so so you uh you took hannah for cash
no no no no no no
it was it was
i'd seen two seasons before they uh
when they offered it to me just to see
what it was and it just looked
compelling it looks like what we did it
really has a great momentum to it
my guys were excited uh that you were
going to be on they want to know if they
could ask you uh a question if that's
okay sure okay all right uh fritzy do
you want to do the joe pesci
impersonation and get that out of the
way for ray we could do that okay go
ahead
wait how am i funny like how am i like a
clown i'm here to amuse you how am i for
how how am i funny you tell me how why
am i so funny to you i got nothing else
to do but make you laugh that's what i'm
here for
what do you think right
it was very good she's a funny guy okay
funny
uh dude they
missed this queue
yeah i know todd how am i funny like how
explain to me no no no you're done
what's so funny about what i mean stop
you you already got it
you know that's
what what you did was better than what i
did so stop get out of here i just kind
of like took it for a while
mclovin you got a question for ray all
right i did all this research there's so
many roles that you're reported to have
passed on is there one i know you're
gonna ask me yeah well no it's fast is
there one that you regret that was true
the only one i would regret
was they came to me
for the first batman and the uh
but i didn't you know i'm saying batman
i'm like oh it's in my 30s batman just
seemed silly and then all of a sudden
that phase took off
i'm not sorry about it but
it's also not what i did
seton
your your uh question
can i ask two
sure do you have a
favorite guitar player since you
mentioned uh the musician thing do you
have a favorite guitar player that you
really like and then my other questions
i really like
stevie ray vaughan i liked
uh
the guy who was with uh what was with
donald fagan um
that no walter but yeah yeah yeah
he was really good too yeah
and what was the other question
oh how did uh growing up in new jersey
impact you as an actor
uh
not not really i i never wanted to do
this i just went to college because my
dad wanted me to and i got into the
university of miami which at that time
you just needed a pulse to get in there
because i walked out of my sats
and uh i was in line take liberal arts
and you had to take a math into history
i don't even know what i'm telling this
story uh
and i just said there's no way i'm going
to do math and history and right to the
left was for the drama department i took
a step over i had a drama class that led
you
in in high school but still never did i
just don't figure it out i don't just
just mess around for a year in miami
paulie your question uh you did two
movies back to back one of them i just
love phoenix you played the cop with a
gambling problem i love that movie but
you did a hbo movie called the rack rat
pack where you played frank sinatra and
it felt like you were singing a lot of
the stuff in the movie how much singing
did you and how tough was that
well i yeah i sang but it was to his
music actually they couldn't even afford
to use
sinatra's music so they had a
a guide who sang just like him like what
you were doing and uh
and so would uh we
that's it
that's it that's all we got ray
that's it yeah
all right yeah well thank you yeah
that's uh your house
what
is this your house no it's my man cave
that's what i mean oh where are you at
your home uh no in connecticut
it's a big big studio i i took over a
kind of a warehouse and made it a man
cave so we
got a basketball court in here and a bar
and
a football field yeah life's good life's
good yes it looks yeah all right i'll
wave to you like lou holtz's
thank you ray good luck with hannah
thank you that's uh ray liotta
field of dreams many saints in newark
and the third and final season of hannah
that premieres november 24th on prime
video